[Music]
dawn is with us dawn's in cincinnati hi
don welcome to the ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call we love
your show thanks for what you do well
thank you how can we help today
yeah um so i have a niece she'll be the
first one to go to college and her
family
and
um
she wants to be a teacher and we listen
to your show enough to know
the college should coincide with the
career path you choose and when it comes
to what you're willing to pay
she has received an 18 000 scholarship
but she would like to go to xavier
university
which is about 52
a year
and she wants to graduate with her
teaching degree and my brother has tried
over and over
to tell her that that is not a good
choice she's even gotten a full ride
to a quote unquote in her mind lesser
schools
he's even tried to briber
saying go to that school and i'll pay
for your final year at xavier and then
you can graduate from there she's just
not listening to any of us and we don't
want her to get
you know having 80 to 100 000
in debt
being a teacher
so do you have any resources or what
have you done in the past to maybe help
these kids to realize this probably
isn't the best decision
duct tape yes
[Laughter]
and bailing wire you can go to tractor
supply your local tractor supply and get
all of your get a chair duct tape into a
chair
i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm tempted but
oh my gosh so she's a stubborn brat
teenager
definitely yeah
and usually those are forced by stubborn
brat parents and she's already
an education snob
so john uh john has a phd in higher ed
and has been the
dean of students at expensive schools
and
other various important positions at
expensive schools so what do you how do
you fix this john
well you got you got a couple of
problems here one is is
usually this attitude is formed
somewhere in the home
right so
often parents will try to wait to the
last minute and correct the behavior
that they may have been a part of and so
if there's any sort of elitism or
they're dumb i can't believe they're
driving that car that's where a parent
sits down with a teenager and says hey
my attitude has been wrong for the last
15 years and i'm sorry right that's not
going to cure this problem overnight but
that's like you've got to start with
that level of humility and normally not
always but this kind of attitude that i
see in 17 year olds and 18 year olds
come on man
that usually comes somewhere from inside
the house
second thing is is
this
some places you can some you can't some
it's hard i would re i would sit down
and say i will not cosign for anything i
will not at some point you got to draw
some really hard boundaries
i'm not going to support this you're not
going to take my car with you you're not
going to take my phone plan with you
some of these things sound draconian and
mean but you're trying to keep a kid
from making a hundred thousand dollars
mistake
right without nothing with an unformed
brain right
their brain is not fully formed at 17.
you're holding a a uh
a full ride to a state school right it's
it it just doesn't work mathematically
it doesn't work professionally
and here's another thing i would do i
would get a teacher
that this person that she trusts
oh that's good it's got student loan
debt and you say i will pay for the
dinner or i'll
parents will pay for coffee
and go say go sit down and ask them if
it's worth it because i had this happen
my friend randall
i had coach basketball at the high
school level and then i was working at a
university and his son was five or six
and he said this is so obnoxious will
you go outside and tell my son to
dribble a basketball like this i said
why don't you go tell him and he goes
because he's going to listen to you
right now
and so there's something about somebody
else saying it sometimes and so send her
out with a teacher that she respects and
looks up to and that teacher will
hopefully set her right
that's good thank you for that but at
the end of the day parents really like i
i've heard this
once i heard a thousand times well i'm
not gonna like take away their car or
their phone i'm still going to put 500
in their account every month i just
think they're making a bad decision and
i always know you're financing their
best that's right look at the parent and
say
how far are you willing to support your
kid making bad choices yeah right i mean
i'm not gonna take away their car
they're only doing cocaine i mean it's
not a problem
like you know that's the kind of thing
so yeah it's uh and going to a private
school does not mean you're doing
cocaine but you know what we're saying
it right you're financing the the the
lack of wisdom there so what we used to
tell our teens uh
about various things because
was that uh i would look at one of them
that was losing their mind and they're
16 years old and i would say listen
there's two people that live inside your
body right now there's a four year old
and a 34 year old
if i can talk to the 34 year old we'll
have a discussion about persuasion
if i'm talking to the four-year-old i'm
gonna freaking tell you what to do and
i'm going to make you do it physically
now like i would a four-year-old you're
going to behave in my house
now we can discuss this and i can tell
you why that's important and why you're
building character and we can have a
persuasive discussion or
i can just make you now what do we want
to do here
and so and i'm going to do that here i'm
going to just sit down and say this is a
dumb butt asinine decision
and i feel like i'm negotiating with you
like you hold any cards in your hand you
don't hold any cards i have all the
freaking money i own your life you are
not an adult i still get to tell you
what to do
and so now we can have a discussion like
two logical adults about this and xavier
is not evil but the number of schools
that she applies to go to you apply to
go to school to honey that actually care
where you got your teaching degree is
precisely zero
unless you want to work at xavier and
then they will care that you went to
xavier but short of that you know you're
signing up for cincinnati city public
schools zero chance you get the job
because you went to xavier versus went
to the other school absolutely precisely
zero there is no data on the planet to
justify this aristocracy crap in higher
ed that these famous schools that are
triple quadruple 5x
expensive are worth a penny more than
the others they're not
now might you learn a little bit more
maybe but the idea that you're gonna do
better as a teacher the idea you're
gonna your career is gonna be on a fast
track because you paid 5x is zero
it's a it's asinine
i wouldn't i want to know why why why
does she want to go to xavier why is she
so set on it
well um she said that it is one of the
best programs uh
in the state for teaching
so so here's what i want to do i hear
that from teenagers all the time
prove it
show me
sit down and show me what what the
rankings mean where the fro i want you
to prove that it's a hundred thousand
dollar difference
why is this car worth 100 000 more than
this other car show me prove it 17 year
old prove it both of them will get you
to the market that's right